this medical facility in umur man in
Sudan's capital Harum is a single room
but provides health care for dozens of
people every day and it's run entirely
by volunteers Ahmed Zade who founded the
center graduated as a doctor only a few
years ago he works at another hospital
during the day and comes here in the
evenings at the start of the conflict
the situation was concerning because of
the attacks by the rapid support forces
on hospitals and healthc Care Centers we
wanted to ensure people had access to
Medical Care and set up the center to
provide first aid and treat chronic
illnesses Sudan's Health sector is
nearly destroyed after 9 months of
conflict between the Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces the UN
says 70% of hospitals around the country
aren't functioning in Harum only a
handful remain open and
volunteers I studied business
administration but came here because
most Medics have left the capital I take
care of Distributing the medicines we
have a card for every patient at the
moment we have 570 patients who come to
get medication for chronic illnesses
donations from volunteers enable the
clinic to remain open despite the center
relying entirely on volunteers and
equipped with little it doesn't only
deal with cold cases Minor Emergency
Operations are sometimes performed here
as well and the also receives patients
with gunshot wounds or shrapnel from an
artillery strike serving as a Lifeline
to many in the city for many people this
is their only option for medical
treatment since being tortured by the
rapid support forces my uncle suffers
from diabetes and hypertension we come
here every day for his treatment and
we've never had to pay a
scent I brought my son here and he was
given oxygen the center is near my home
and the treatment is free and that
matters because there is no
work volunteers say they'll continue to
do what they can to help those left
vulnerable by the conflict in hopes of
making a difference in their lives and
those of their loved ones hia Morgan Al
jaaz make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer